[Music]
and booby-trap news these are my closet
Wars that's because you're just extra
breast implants have been recalled after
being linked to a rare type of cancer no
texture texture I'd like the insects
Laura Lee parent huh well what's a
textured employ okay so there's two
types that I've recently learned is it
smooth yeah and then like it's textured
like it's kind of like fuzzy like a
fabric so why would you have a triangle
II mainly I felt oh yeah it's kind of
like a belt looking why would you get
the other one versus the smooth I think
I have this one's one yeah I have a
smooth one so apparently smooth is more
popular in the United States probably
textured is more popular in Canada and
Australia interest so I wonder if it
feels different
like fleece boobies I heard the Queen's
implants I heard that all of the wall
implants have recently been linked to
some kind of cancer breast implant
illness that's what it's called Wow
sorry good I think hasn't been declared
as like a actual illness but a lot of
women on the internet are saying like I
have these symptoms this is what was
happening to me I took them out and they
went away so a lot of women are saying
that that's what it is I did seeing that
yeah maybe maybe we'll just reject it
their bodies are rejecting I like it's
kind of like what is this foreign thing
in my body yeah so your body's trying to
fight this thing and maybe that's what
well there was a doctor who used to do
it in LA and actually my friend got it
done with her and then that doctor just
left the practice altogether because of
this new thing she's like gets is pretty
dangerous stuff so they are staying here
so it's called breast implant associated
and a plastic large cell lymphoma
that's a lot of what I al CL even
acronyms long
I'll see ya I feel like Cheerilee yeah
thanks PA try marching for that bro yes
so this is a rare form of cancer and so
they're saying that the most common
symptom is excessive fluid buildup
around the breast implant which can
cause pain swelling or lumps in the
breast or armpit symptoms usually occur
between 3 and 14 years after implant
placement so they're saying that it's
important for you to recognize the
symptoms and then go to your plastic
surgeon that's scary
um so there's name that according to the
FDA there have been 573 cases oh that's
not along this thing that's not a lot
yeah yeah if you think about how many
women get their breasts done exactly cuz
in 2018 three hundred and fourteen
thousand people received resident 14,314
[ __ ] it's more than so then okay so
then 573 cases 33 patient deaths
worldwide Jesus and out of four I'm
sorry and four hundred eighty one of
those cases are attributed to this
specific company's implants called
allergen and they said that twelve of
the thirteen patients that died were
from that manufacturer oh yeah three
hundred thousand worldwide or three
hundred thousand in the US the u.s. damn
they got leaky leaky banks the breasts
implementation is the most popular
plastic surgery operation worldwide our
us I think worldwide it's the most
common we're not elzear's you think oh I
think those are just more like nicer you
know see yeah so they're saying that
that textured type of implant is what is
mainly the the people like these women
that are developing this mainly but they
have that kind of implant but they are
saying that there are risks with even
the smooth and they also mentioned that
if you're not experiencing any symptoms
that it's not safe
you to get them removed without
experiencing symptoms because it could
lead to more risk yeah an autoimmune
disease because it's just like
unnecessary so yeah I mean if you think
about it like a lot of times for breast
implants you like the doctor tells you
like when I went to go get mine he's
like I do him all the time like don't
worry and it's such a quick surgery like
you don't even spend the night it takes
like two hours by the next day you can
actually be walking around you just
can't really move your arms your pickup
heavy stuff you know yeah um and so you
feel like I'm fine you know but it's
really a big major surgery that just
happened where they're putting something
doesn't belong in your body creating a
pocket for it and then closing it up you
know so it's like we don't ever really
think about like the such high risk that
comes with the breast implant
augmentation but it's so normal it's
super normal and almost died doing it
did it Kanye's mom died from that
liposomes lipo
oh okay I'd be she I don't think she
died from the lipo I think she died
because she had a previous heart
condition that one was mixed when that
would that seizure like it was what
killed her not actually oh but the
anesthesia
yeah her body was just rejecting the
implants oh your friend and she almost
died you Wow
that's so scary they are saying that
about 5% of breast implants sold in the
US are textured so it's not a huge for
us well yeah because they're more
popular in Canada Australia but if you
don't know like about any of this like
you go to your doctor and you trust them
you're like okay what size fits me what
do you think I should yeah like what do
you think I should do and of course no
plastic surgeon wants to have a death on
their on the record because it's plastic
surgery it's cosmetic it's not supposed
to kill anybody but if a plastic surgeon
has had someone die on their table
they're not gonna tell you so it's
really super important that you do your
research way before you go to your
doctor what's the difference between
texture what's the texture thing again
remember felt seen one a tons I used to
I hosted this show called the Playboy
morning show and I saw too many of them
oops oh no no no no so a lot of raw raw
titties here all like the back
oh no no yeah it's just like smooth
I used to sterilize them and then part
of the sterilization process sterilized
the implants himself it wasn't no it's
not the implants of the scisors so like
the the bag that they put in first to
like it's like a cone like stretch that
area type of thing and then they put
it's like literally a cone it's such a
graphic surgery you should watch it I'm
used to how thin is it the the aim that
the bad yeah so like the bag I've seen
commercials and the commercials are in
YouTube you can literally drop it from
like the roof and it won't leak or it
won't open you can run a car over it and
it won't pop what I was gonna mention is
that part of the procedure of cleaning
these implants or the cisors is you have
to massage them for three minutes
straight to like get up feeling
someone's future Katie so it's a size
they're not a future that's like being a
Victoria's Secret and feeling the bras
yeah three minutes it's like this is
gonna be all someone's tape implants
they develop a logic so these implants
when they're getting sterilized they
develop air pockets so you have to
massage the air pockets out oh yeah I'd
be I just be there like and they feel
like in the special enzyme that like
breaks up the blood and all that stuff
and I'm just there and I'm like this is
funny
he's like yes really is it a liquid or
anything and they're like just a
silicone they'll be bare so like that
what the best way my doctor explained it
to me he's like if your implements to
rip yeah nothing's gonna leak out
literally just like gummy gummy material
yeah he went I went the one what implant
did you guess I did silicone okay yeah
there's also saline though so the Saline
is just one so if it opens up it would
leak and I think in the United States
you have to be over 21 to get gummy bear
if you're below and you get an implants
you get the ceiling wow I don't know why
that is but my doctor did tell me
because I while I was already 25 but he
did tell me like if you are below 21
they have to do sing and Mexican you
could be any age though
you could wait for my 15th birthday
that's what I want him but my mom was
like hang up
that this type of cancer is extremely
rare and it has a greater than ninety
percent cure rate when you just remove
the implant device issue I know but how
do you even like recognize it well this
intently fluid they say that it causes
weakened swelling and like lumps your
boobs get even bigger
not cute bigger that's what enflamed and
random Buffalo huh damn you know be
crazy if like they figure out how to use
stem cells and duplicate like the
mammary glands so they could just inject
some [ __ ] and let it grow naturally well
that kills that claim that it makes your
boobs bigger if those like those
supplements it's natural boobs are just
fat they're just like fat deposits are
naturally there you know so some girls
by genetics have bigger boobs than
others you know so I don't know that you
can actually tell your body like I want
fat deposits here you know thank you
guys I might be like I want to hear me
stem cells stem cells would be sick
themselves it might also 3d printing
brother mix with stem cells is supposed
to be the cure for baldness that was
just really what you gonna do like prune
out some hair and put it on your head
like that and it fuses to you oh I think
that's the idea is that they're gonna
scream for your head you're 3d print the
[ __ ] hairs and then they'll inject
stem stem cells in your [ __ ] well
already taking the patch of the back of
your pretty crazy you know what the [ __ ]
does Bosley do cuz they don't yeah they
take your own hair and then what they
just move the package I want to do that
yeah take a trip from the back of the
majors remember those infomercials for
the spring I wanna get it you just
sprayed let me show you that you could
swim oh [ __ ] but then it runs all down
no that's the point they try they show
you that you can swim because it doesn't
match in your hair you can swim but then
the kid is the family of five next to
you think so you took a [ __ ] before
nose nose job procedure that they're
trying to find out with doing your nose
job but just with sound vibrations
no you couldn't like mold the cartilage
it was a while back looks insane really
yeah whatever that works with bone it's
just Carlos oh yes the workers or your
your actual well your nose is cartilage
I thought this is bone up here no its
cartilage actually what do you you know
when you look at a small okay so what it
doesn't like take it away cuz I had too
much cartilage I don't know I think it's
to mold it so I get skinnier I don't
know I don't know I heard that there's a
method where you can move your jaw if
you do it enough YouTube video you don't
move your job buddy
your tongue don't move your jaw it's
your tongue position oh how do you do it
you know yeah Susi's thing limbering the
tip huh and you can you change eyebrow
shape just by doing that
ya could make your head a pointed tip if
you really work out if I do this every
day it'll change the shape of my face
that's what my mom actually the same
doctor guy he says like you know how you
have a short like some people can have
like a short distance here and so they
tend to it's hard for them to keep their
mouth completely closed because
naturally all your lenders yeah so
that's like I not that I have a short
thing but my mouth muscles are weaker so
if I completely like relax my mouth my
mouth automatically wants to open isn't
that everybody know there's some people
like you can naturally keep his mouth
closed that's right notice if you go I
think if everyone goes I just relax
everything when you might not when he's
closed your teeth touches each other
no hmm my teeth not like this I don't
know now because I'm thinking about it
maybe I mean I don't know but do you
sleep with your mouth open
yeah yeah you also have weak mouth
muscles we all go to so then that doctor
saying that you can exercise that by
doing certain facial we make sure you
know that part of it is not chewing
natural raw fibers enough because our
diet isn't count or no gum helps
oh really Brody's supposed to take every
letter of the alphabet in vitamins a day
iron zinc calcium blah blah blah now I
got a [ __ ] eat wheat or something to
keep my jaw strong yeah did you meet me
along jet to chew tobacco yeah
gum helps he says humans are resilient
that's why people can eat [ __ ] rust
and metal we made it this far and live
we're gonna die it's not that we're
gonna die it's just that we're not as
like healthy as we can be or like our
teeth in our mouth muscles aren't as
strong as they can be
yes you're right you ugly I'll eat it oh
you ugly a do you want to change it you
just gotta put your tongue on the roof
of your mouth
yeah starting with all singing every day
[Music]
[Music]